bit of breaking news to bring you which
is that in the last few minutes the
parents of harry dunn have lost their
high court battle against the foreign
office
the 19 year old died when his motorbike
collided with a car being driven
on the wrong side of the road by
american and sirculus the wife of a
diplomat his parents
claimed the foreign office wrongly
decided mrs circulas had diplomatic
immunity
and unlawfully obstructed a police
investigation
into the crash or for the latest we can
speak to sky correspondent becky johnson
who joins me now from charlton in
oxfordshire becky
yeah this is a big blow to harry dunn's
family they have
always maintained that they did not
believe that ann sakula should have been
given
diplomatic immunity and therefore that
the foreign office decision
uh to grant that to her which then
enabled her to
leave the country she is of course still
in the u.s uh has
has not um an extradition uh request was
not granted she is
is not being uh required to return back
to the uk to face the charge of death by
dangerous driving
that she faces they have always said she
should never have been granted that
diplomatic immunity in the first place
and that's why they
took the foreign office to the high
court to make that argument of course
the high
court this morning ruling that
anserkulis did have
diplomatic immunity effectively agreeing
with that foreign office decision
now the family have already said that
they're just taking in this decision now
they have already said that they are
going to
appeal this now to the court of appeal
they they do not believe that their
fight stops here they have always said
that they will do whatever they can to
get justice
for harry who of course was just 19 when
he was killed on his motorcycle
outside raf croton in northamptonshire
they've always said that that fight will
not end until they get justice for harry
and therefore they say that this is just
another stage in that fight and they
will appeal this decision
that's been handed down by the high
court